what's up guys my name is the channel
welcome back to my game engine
series so last time we took a look at
our whole scene class and how we could
integrate the ecs our entity component
system
how we could start using that to
actually create entities and add
components to them check out that video
if you haven't already
today we're going to be continuing on
with that and i specifically want to
talk about
the concept of an entity class in
hazel now this is probably one of those
things that's better to show in the
actual code so i will very
professionally using my hotkey
transition to
this scene where we can also we can also
see all of this code
um now i do want to start off by saying
that okay 220 zoom
um today's video again is going to be a
little bit more of an introduction to
how we're going to use everything our
scene class at the moment if we take a
look
uh has this create entity command or
function which is great and it returns
this entity
id essentially from and but obviously
this was
temporary and that's what we're gonna
gonna work on today to get rid of this
temporary like registry we don't want to
be returning anything to do with and
into the client so hazelnut sandbox all
of any game written in hazel
should basically not know anything about
and other other than everything that we
expose
because instead of going through that
api we obviously want to keep everything
consistent with our hazel api
whilst using kind of whilst using end in
the back end
so in other words what do we actually
need from this api
and why are we creating an entity class
in the first place i want to mention
that this is not something that you have
to do again this is very subjective this
is
all up to you and how you actually uh
you know what kind of programming style
you like using now
i'm not completely against
object-oriented programming
like it seems to be the trend these days
that everyone hates on that
i um the thing is i don't i don't kind
of
i don't and this might be a topic for
another video but i don't really like
align myself with a coding uh
not really a convention but like a
paradigm i guess i don't really call
myself an object-oriented programmer or
a you know non-object-oriented
programmer or like a data-driven
programmer whatever i don't really care
about terminologies i just write code
the way that i like writing code
and in practice that that involves kind
of using objects
um and object-oriented programming in
certain circumstances where i
deem it like where i like it essentially
and where i think it will actually help
the code um and then on the flip side
you know if i don't think that objects
are necessary or if i don't think
object-oriented programming is a good
fit for
for what i'm trying to do i'm not going
to go down the hole like oh let's create
a class for everything and use that
that's silly as well now i'm not the
best programmer in the world
contrary to what some of you might think
um
so i you know don't you don't have to
listen to me this is just me
um you know saying that you know as far
as i'm aware and
you know just in my general programming
i like doing
certain things a certain way and uh
there's you know who's to say that
this is right or wrong this is just how
i roll and unless it like severely
impacts
people's readability or performance or
things like that i don't really see a
problem with it
so um long story short the way that i
like to do this
is and i think the best way to approach
this
now that we're a lot more chill with
these live streamers videos that aren't
really planned
i'm having to come up with stuff on the
spot but it's good because i think it
will also
translate to me um maybe including more
information than others
than i otherwise would finding it hard
to talk right now
um so this is our kind of entity
situation right now
this is this is how we're using the api
i always like using i
i always like looking at the usage of an
api
or even fabricating some kind of
fictional usage of the api like a future
usage of the api
to try and come up with the api in the
first place i think that's a really good
way to write code so in other words
what is the api what is my dream api for
dealing with this how do i want to be
able to create entities
well it makes sense the creating entity
should be done on the scene so this is
pretty much a perfect line
of code here the only bad thing here is
that this is actually an end entity
not the best thing in the world um i
would like some kind of hazel entity
here
even if at this point entity is just
basically like using entity as a you and
32 t like this
which is essentially what it kind of is
right um so we could probably even write
code like that
or whatever um and you know you you
would get away you could get away with
this because essentially that's what
a that's what an end entity actually is
so in other words this would be fun
now um you know the point is though i
don't want to be
returning anything from ant i want this
to be a hazel thing
so again hazel entity is probably like
regardless of whether it's this or
something a little bit more deep like a
class or a struct
um it's going to be something like that
so that's kind of step one
the other thing is obviously this
atrocious situation here where where not
only
getting the registry which we shouldn't
even know about because that's an
implementation detail we're also
in placing which is a which is an ant
function which has a lowercase e so it
doesn't even look like it's part of like
hazel's api
right this is also not something that we
want so essentially what we want to now
be able to do
is replace this code with something that
we can actually have as part of hazel's
api to
add a component to an entity so how do
we add a component to an entity
now the simplest case is probably
something like add component
but then like we're doing that to the
scene so
should add component take in an entity
like this and then
like in my opinion this is becoming a
little bit
like this is becoming a little bit of a
burst
it's becoming a little bit too uh
wordy i guess um you know it's just it's
i mean you're adding a component to the
active scene yes because everything
exists in the scene
but first of all do we really need to
think about this as like
okay i'm adding components to my scene
which is the registry
rather than to an actual entity because
we as humans when we look
at an entity in our game engine when
we're looking at it in the actual editor
where kind of we expect to click on the
entity
and then see all of the components
belonging to the entity
in like the inspector or the properties
panel or whatever
right we don't really want to click on
the scene and then get a list of
components and then kind of search by
entity or whatever our brains don't work
that way
even if if we look at the actual
underlying data structure
and the actual implementation we can see
that yeah there is just an array of
components and entities don't exist
entities are just used to kind of
match different components together
right
even though that's the implementation
detail and that's kind of the programmer
way of thinking maybe
maybe if you've written your own ecs so
you know how ant works really well
and you're kind of in that mindset you
might think like that but that
is not really how i think
our brain works when we think of this
our brain works in the most naive way
possible i think
in this circumstance which is i have an
entity and an entity has a list of
components
i want to add component to an entity i
don't want to add a component to a scene
even though that's my that might be how
it works that's not how i work
right and so because of that i like
obviously developing apis that make a
lot of sense to the human
um in general because well that's what
it is it's an application programming
interface like it's something
that we use as humans to interface with
code
right um that's how i see it so in other
words
what that and that's where this object
oriented thing comes into place
what i would like to do is instead of
doing this i don't want to be i don't
want to do this i want to actually add a
component
to this square essentially right
um that's it because that's really clear
right if i oh what do i want to do with
this entity well i want to add a
component to it or i want to get a
component from the square
right that's how it works that's how
unity c sharp api works
right i mean what we are kind of the
game object ourselves so we can easily
just call it get component it's like
kind of like a superclass method and all
that stuff
but ultimately if we did have a c plus
api and we retrieved an entity and we
actually had an empty like this which is
essentially the same as unity's game
object
um then obviously all we do is
just call getcomponent on the actual
entity
now the problem obviously here is that
the entity isn't doesn't own
the components though so how does the
entity retrieve the components
and that's where my little entity class
comes in and that's what we're going to
be doing today
so what i'm going to do is inside scene
i'm going to make a new class called
entity
and it's going to be this is again going
to be really simple
so namespace hazel
class entity
um we're going to include scene which
means we can't include entity in scene
that's important to note
otherwise we'll end up with a recursive
include um we'll deal with empty
construction and stuff like that in a
minute
um we can include ant
and i probably yeah i will have to
include ant actually
so include and what even is it m.h.p i
don't know what did we do in scene
scene we didn't anticipate yep
okay um so what this is going to end up
being this
entity is it's going to be a very thin
kind of easily constructable
destructible stack object essentially
that is going to all it's going to do is
provide a convenient set of functions
to end right so in other words what i
should be able to do
is i need two pieces of the puzzle here
i need the id
of my entity and i need the scene that
is the context of the entity where does
the entity live in
right so in other words where is that
registry if i have those two pieces of
information
i can do anything i want right and this
is going to function as a wrapper
for that so the way that i like to do
this is
add in those oops there's that russian
again add in those
um those pieces of information so we
have ant entity
being our like entity handle i'll say
and then also we need some kind of scene
now
i don't want to take a ref to a scene
because
i don't want this scene to i don't want
the entity to
somehow own its own the scene right so
if i did this and i just had my scene
here as my context
then since this is like a strong
reference to a scene
object if i still have one of these
entities floating around which
again is just it it's not even like
something that you store
right it's just like a it's just an it's
just an interface really
into like all of the entity functions we
want if that's the case
then i'm not gonna my scene's not gonna
get released from memory
what i ultimately want here is basically
a weak ref
right i want to have a weak graph of a
scene which is basically just a way for
us to have a scene pointer
and then we can just you know if it but
it's not gonna it's not gonna take any
ownership
so in other words we can check before we
use it is it valid is it pointing to a
valid object or has seen been deleted
and if it hasn't been deleted then we
can go through with this
again that's probably what you want to
do in the optimal case i'll leave that
up to you if you want to do something
like that in your engine if you're
following along
at the moment we're we're not even we're
in no remote circumstance to be using
weak wraps especially well
because the reason i really don't want
to do this is because
um we are still doi we as we're still
dealing with shared pointers and sequels
pluses classes whereas
uh in the future we're going to be
switching to an intrusive reference
counting system that we're going to
write
um and since we're going to write that
we're going to have to write our own
kind of version of the weak ref and
anyway
to keep matters simple i'm just going to
have a role pointed to a scene okay
so this is going to have a scene roll
pointer and it's going to have an entity
handle that is it because this is
relatively lightweight this should be 12
bytes of memory
on a 64-bit build like this um
it's fine to copy this it's fine to
construct it and destruct it at will
you can do whatever you want with this
this is not something that you need to
be passing by const reference everywhere
it's not something that you want to
retain you can easily construct it in a
scope use it for whatever you want and
then discard it
that is how this object is meant to be
used and you'll probably see that
throughout this
because really as you'll see in a minute
it's just it's just a way for us to call
certain functions and make our code look
cleaner
that's it we basically push in all the
data we want basically the parameters to
these functions we push them into
an object like this and then whatever
functions we call
since these things i'm pointing at my
screen for some reason since these
things are actually
like part of this object they're members
they're
available to the functions that we write
in this class and we can take advantage
of that and that's what we're doing
so to um basically to show you what i
mean
if we say template type name t um
this would be like something like has
component right
has component so we're checking to see
if this entity has a component
well what do we do we call scene then we
get into the registry which we're going
to change in a minute because really we
want
this and i'm going to make entity a
friend the class of scenes that we have
access to that
and then i think we just do has t and
then
m entity handle right and that's what we
return
if we hop over to c really quickly and i
just down the bottom here i'll say
friend class entity
just that we have access to this that's
that's what we can do to see if this
entity does in fact
have um does in fact have
this whatever the component we ask it
doesn't have this component right
so um let's quickly just add in some
extra stuff here so
entity and i'll say entity handle
um and then scene pointer scene
um we will probably
okay i'll make just to keep no i don't
know what i should do okay i will make a
cpp file for this
um i don't yeah i didn't really want to
just because i didn't feel it's
necessary but on the flip side i do want
to keep that header file
as easy to read as possible so if we
have even something as simple as this
constructor
and obviously a shallow copy constructor
is all we need
for copying and yeah you can you can
obviously
this is this class is intended to be
copied um
whenever we need and scene scene
oh right i was wondering why that wasn't
auto completing because i forgot
the name space for for the class um all
right so
um yeah so that's
that's it and then you know if we kind
of and i'll just you know add in the
basic stuff
like const entity other this is the copy
constructor
just to explicitly say that we actually
have that copy constructor there and
that we're we're intending for it to be
used
again this is not something that you
need to add um but i like adding it just
to
just just as like an extra kind of tip
to the programmer but still as well
provided in this case so it is kind of
redundant
so uh do as you will um anyway so now
that we've got this the idea is that
first of all create entity supposed to
be returning an entity
right but even if it doesn't even if we
kind of wind up with a situation where
somehow we've got just the entity id but
we also know what scene is part of
guess what we can easily just say entity
and this is inside hazel we can say
um actually let me quickly include
entity here okay we can just say
entity you know square whatever which
i'll call square entity
um is just equal to uh square which is
the ant id
and then active scene which i think is a
um
a shared pointer so we'll do get and
that's it right um
it's an incomplete type yeah i think i
don't think this actually includes it
um editor layer includes oh it does
include hazel with edge so why is that
an incomplete
what's incomplete about this
that should be very complete that's a
bit odd
okay it's working now never mind visual
studio um
so yeah so now we have this right and
then we can just ask it hey
do you have house component do you have
a transform component
and now do you see how nice that api is
isn't this just really nice
i think it's really nice let me know
what you think but i think it's really
nice
now obviously constructing it all the
time and that this is the beauty of it
right
if you're in a situation where you just
have an end an end i'd like an end
entity id
right and you have the active scene you
can easily just in that function scope
or wherever you are just quickly
construct this
hazel dev does this all the time okay
it's basically built on this
on this system if it wasn't like
anything that has to do with like
hey we have an entity we have a scene i
want to start
using the entity api we basically go
through this because it's really nice to
read the code like this
and it just makes everything a lot
easier um
so that's how all of that works okay now
obviously
create entity still returns an end
entity which is wrong i want it to
return an
entity um so what we'll do here
is uh i think we will okay so this
should return an entity we'll just add
in
entity as a uh forward declaration here
um that should be fine um and then
this is just going to return registry
create yeah register create which
creates that new id for us and then this
right and then that is how we're going
to construct entity and we obviously
have to include entity in our cpp file
here
all right there we go so
registry goes away now and then we have
to add
a whole bunch of functions and so we'll
start with i guess the add component
function so how does the add component
function works now we don't want to
necessarily
lose all of the nice api that n gives us
a lot of it we simply want to take and
kind of forward all of our arguments
across to end basically
and so the a particularly nice case that
ant
actually has is this as you can see if
we're constructing
this component we can we don't just have
to basically say that hey we want to in
place this component
we can actually provide it with the
constructor arguments to construct that
component kind of in place
uh the same way that we would do it with
a vector when we want to like
well essentially when we use the
in-place api versus the pushback api
we're able to actually
forward our constructor arguments so
that it gets constructed in place
rather than in this stack frame and then
copied so it's kind of like we're just
saying
hey here are the arguments i want you to
use to construct this
component in this case rather than
having to make the component ourselves
and then give it
to um our entity registry
so to make that happen we basically need
to write a templated function that just
forwards our arguments across to
um the perfectly forwards our arguments
across
into uh anteland so to do that
um we'll have to add a
variatic template here that is basically
going to
work for any any number of arguments and
then we're going to take those arguments
and just forward them to end because we
definitely don't want to deal with them
here
so t reference at component because of
course we still want to return the
component by reference just like
just like ant does and this is
essentially going to return
scene registry and then in place along
with as you can see
the component type and then all of the
arguments but we don't need to provide
the arguments in the template arguments
we can just write them here we have um
um what do we call it args and then
args dot dot dot i have to remember the
syntax for this
um so essentially all we're doing here
is we're saying that and we need to
actually provide
these arguments uh like
this and this is this is a little bit
confusing
um probably not going to discuss it too
much because it's more of a c plus thing
but essentially this is a variatic
template this is these are
this is these are all of our variables
that we're passing in
and then we're saying that like don't
unpack them here
just let's just forward them all the way
to
end because and as you can see the in
place also takes in
the same thing right so this is just a
way for us to say don't unpack all these
all this variable number of arguments
and handle them here which we could do
we're saying that just take them and
pass them up pass them along
so that's what's happening here so we're
in placing entity handle with a
variable number of arguments which will
make up the constructor arguments
and then that will of course return a
reference to whatever type we pass in
here
and that is what we're returning pretty
simple
now get component is also another simple
one
type name t t reference get components
this is just going to be scene registry
um get and then
t and then mnt handle all right really
easy
now you can see that this code is quite
verbose though that's the thing like i
mean we wouldn't be falling out
forwarding arguments if we weren't in
here but in general like you know scene
register blah blah
whereas we're able to just call squanty
has component so
that's another nice benefit it just kind
of makes everything a lot more simple
now with get component for example and
potentially with ad component
you probably want to add some asserts
here especially because they're just in
debug just to make sure that we don't
have that component so you could easily
just run has component
um let's say because otherwise it's
going to assert
within end and that might be harder to
debug because ent is not that easy to
read
so we want to keep this as easy as
possible so we can just say has
component t
right or specifically not house
component t right
so this is just gonna um when we can say
entity
already has components
components that's correct all right and
then same with get component
um we want to make sure that we actually
do have the component
um and if not we can say entity does not
have components okay so these are just
some ways for us and i'll just get rid
of these spaces these are just some ways
for us to just you know be a little bit
more in control with what's going on and
make sure that we're not asserting
inside and
because if we are resetting inside and
it might be a little bit more
it might be a little bit more difficult
to debug
okay um what else do we need i'll remove
components an important one i'm just
looking at hazel dev code for reference
by the way so if you see me glancing
over here that's what i'm doing
because i'm not going to pretend to
remember everything that i wrote
over like weeks um so
remove component obviously is very
simple and we'll simply call
uh scene registry
remove t from
entity handle and again we'll just
assert that uh
that we do have that component that
we're trying to remove
okay i think that's it i mean if i look
at other stuff
um like we had there's a lot more in
this class inside hazeldev
um there's a lot more um it's
not needed at this point probably
there's some implicit cast operators
going on there's some
uh convenience operator operators for
like retrieving the transform
so instead of calling get component
transform you can just call dot entity
dot transform
that's another really important thing
because it's really it's every entity
should have a transform
there's also like uuid stuff which we're
not no we should probably talk about
that soon shouldn't we
um yeah we're going to need to have some
kind of like globally unique or
universally unique
identifier system as well for our engine
and that's
going to be a video that's going to be a
big topic to talk about as well because
that's a very important system as well
for a game engine anyway
let's not get too ahead of ourselves so
now that we have this
right um and uh so this is now a hazel
entity which means we don't even need
this
now we should just be able to say like
square house component transform
let's let's make this a little bit
better though let's
um actually and again you know we could
you know say registry create
get that kind of um entity id and then
say
registry and place the component and do
all of that stuff but we're not gonna do
any of that
because instead we're going to take this
and we're going to say
entity you know um nc entity equals
registry
create that's what we're going to return
but then we're also going to say
entity.add component transform
all right transform component and that
way
now all of our entities that we ever
create will have a transform component
as long as we create them using this api
um same with like a tag component so
let's add that right now
we'll add a tag component
um tag components
tag component obviously it doesn't exist
yet
so now we'll go to components and we
will add
i'll make it the first thing here tag
component and this is obviously going to
be an sd string
tag um you might want to make this
maybe not an std string um
so tag component we'll say default and
then we'll just
we'll make sure that it's like copyable
and everything um
well copyable it will be but we'll make
sure that it
is constructable with a string like this
as well
and and the default construction is
going to be um we could make the default
constructor like unknown
i don't know i'll just we'll just leave
it blank um tag
tag tag tag tag tag
all right so now every entity has a tag
component um it doesn't necessarily have
to have a tag component
uh here's what we'll do we'll go to
scene we will actually make our entire
tag component because i think that's
going to be useful
um cons std string name so when we
create an entity with us by name however
i'll make it so that we can have an
empty name here
um and if we end you know
maybe i'll write it like this actually
um
if we have this here then we can just
check to see um so with the tag
right we'll add it so this is auto tag
and we'll say if name is empty
then tag.tag equals
what should we have i don't even know i
can just call it entity
or unnamed entity or empty entity i
don't know we'll just call it entity
um otherwise
i guess we'll write this as like one of
these
uh ternary operators so
if the name is empty it will be
this otherwise obviously we'll assign it
to name
okay so now we have an entity with a tag
and
transform um and no matter what it will
be that so we can
now call this our square right
and then the idea is that um we don't
need this we don't need to add transform
anymore
all we do here now for this green square
that we've got is we in place
a layer and place anything we add a
sprite renderer component
you can see our arguments still get
forwarded to end and everything
still kind of works as normal which is
great um
we can uh again with square entity so
why are we doing that oh just so we can
control it okay great
so that's that's kind of good as well um
that's a good example so if we go back
here instead of this being an
ant entity this is now a hazel entity
right which is just an empty
and then down here instead of you know
doing all this stuff we just say
square entity get component
sprite render component dot color
right and that's our color that we
modify let's hit f5 see if all of that
compiles and
actually works no
no default constructor for entity and we
need
yeah okay yep that's also important so
we should have a default constructor for
entity
um i'll add that in and i'll also just
say that um
uh i don't know if we can properly
initialize this i guess we can
no uh entity can we
it's the thing is it's an anti-fly
d-type
enum class entity is an id type how do i
initialize that with a value properly
because i really yeah i guess that i
just want yeah i need to make sure that
these are set like this the reason is
it's also valid to have an empty entity
like an entity that actually doesn't
have it
doesn't exist and what i'll actually do
is i'll say
operator um i guess this will be a oops
bull oh no it's operator bull isn't it
advanced return m entity
m entity handle it doesn't equal zero
okay this is just a way for us to check
to see if
the entity is valid or not right so now
that we have that default construct
everything will compile but the cool
thing we
the cool thing is at this point you know
we could for example
um inside our renderer or wherever we
use this check to see if square entity's
a thing just by saying if square entity
and if square entity is set to something
then it's going to work right and we can
test that out by also
just leaving that in there even though
obviously we know that it's going to
exist at this point in time
all right sprite render component no
overloaded function takes two arguments
okay um sprite renderer components
no overloaded function takes two
arguments
what's going on here and that's coming
from
uh oh from our component function
what don't we have one argument
surprise that's the sprite render
component right
components
that's definitely definitely a
constructor that takes into
so did i do this wrong
oh i've still got square in here so
obviously it's trying to yeah
i've still got square in there because
that was from the in-place function that
required the entity okay
false alarm everything is right
all right there we go there's our green
square obviously it's valid because
we're seeing the square color here and
we can still change the square
everything still works like it did
before which is great
let's do one final thing and um when we
display this let's also say i am gui um
text and we will say
um and let's actually let's be all cool
let's add a separator so that we
um know this is all kind of grouped
together for our square entity
um and then we'll um and i guess i can
just
do the separate inside here um
and we'll say text let's see
uh percentage s here for a string and
we'll set this to be
square entity get component
tag component dot tag okay
and i don't know if i'm gui is happy
with we might need to give it a c string
here
um what's why is it so upset
okay that's a little bit odd
but fair enough
order tag
equals that tag does his string all
right because we had a temporary there
and you don't want to be taking pointers
temporaries like that
um but also what's no something's still
wrong here
um what's going on
what am i doing wrong this is that's a
string right
error type so that just didn't work at
all get component
oh
i don't know why you guys watch my
videos honestly clearly i need to
i need to learn how to actually
write code okay so there's square and
you can see it's called square right
it's got the name square now obviously
in this case i mean
it seems silly but i could call this
like green square
or something like that you can see i'm
just giving the entity a name by setting
its tag component essentially
and then we obviously see that over here
green square and we can change the
square color to anything
we want all right so that is the
entity class um really kind of
easy next time i want to talk about
camera entities let me quickly
switch over and this is very
unprofessional but anyway
next time we're going to be talking
about cameras and how we're going to set
up the camera
to function in the entity component
system i think that'll be a fun little
episode
let me know what you guys think of this
entity api i really like it i think that
it's really
um it makes the code look really clean
and that's my kind of preferred way
of doing everything to do with kind of
entities and components as far as like
how i want to use them as a game
developer not a game engine developer
um and also how how i would expect them
to appear in the scripting language so i
think that's why
it's good that it is the way that it is
anyway thank you guys for watching
um if you did enjoy the video please
don't forget to hit the like button also
help support
the series on patreon.com thank you to
everyone for helping to support the
series don't forget that you will get
access to
live streams of me developing hazel dev
and also the hazel dev code if you help
support
um me on patreon thank you all for
watching i'll see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you